[拍手]
can
[音楽]
you
do
[音楽]
benvenuto
voodoo
[音楽]
def
ファイル
[音楽]
ていん
想像してください
あなたは今劇場の客席に座ってマジック
ショーを見ています
舞台の上ではマジシャンがマジックを応援
しています
その横ではアシスタントが微笑みながら
立っています
マジック代わり客席からは大きな拍手
舞台の上にいる男性と女性は並んでを時期
をし
舞台の幕が下ります
ここで皆さんに質問です
皆さんは今男性と女性どちらをマジシャン
だと思いましたか
男性を本気ちゃんだと思った方は正直に
教えてください
実はそれ
ジェンダーバイアスという男性と女性の
役割を無意識のうちに区別してしまう
偏ったものの見方かもしれません
私たちは女性マジシャンと呼ばれます
女性のマジシャンを表すその言葉に私は
違和感を覚えていました
男性のマジシャンを紹介するときに男性
マジシャンのマルマルさんですと言う
でしょうか
きっとマジシャンのマルマルさんですと
紹介すると思います
しかし私たち女性のマジシャンのことを
紹介するとき必ずと言っていいほど女性
マジシャンのという言葉がつきます
そのことについて私はなぜ女性であること
を強調するんだろうと思っていました女性
の活躍がメディアで取り上げられるときも
肩書きに女性のとか美人狩り何というよう
な女性性を強調する言葉が多く使われます
その呼び方に何かモヤモヤした違和感が
ありました
ある時他のマジシャンと話をしていてその
違和感私以外にも感じている人がいると
知りました
彼女たちと話すうちにその違和感の正体が
分かりました
女性マジシャンという言葉で来られるとき
私たちは一人の個性あるマジシャンでは
なく
女性というくくりで見られていることに
気づいたのです
そこで私たちが求められていたのは華やか
さや愛嬌
色気時には若さでありそれぞれの個性や
技術というよりも女性であるということの
方が重要視されていました
もちろんそれらも個性の一部ですから勝ち
にはなり得ます
メリットを受け取るために支えないことは
笑顔で受け流すという考え方もわかります
ですが女性であることを強調することで
受けるダメージも大きいと私は感じてい
ます
実際にお客様からマジックなんかしなくて
も顔を見ているだけでいいと言われたり
マジック中に手を触られたり
露出の多い服を着るよう言われたりする
こともありましたん
しかし今まで私だけが感じていると思って
いた問題が
他の人たちも同じように抱えていたと知っ
て
女性マジシャンという言葉に無意識のうち
にコントロールされていたことに気づき
ました私たちは女性男性というくくりでは
なくそれぞれの個性を活かしさらに多様化
していくことでこの無意識のコントロール
から逃れることができると思います
実際にここ数年の私たちマジシャンは
すでに多様化していると思います
しかし男性のマジシャンからはまだまだ
女性マジシャンは差別化できていないと
言われることもありそれは彼らが私たちを
女性マジシャンという枠組みの中でしか見
ていないからなのではと思いますですが
これはきっとマジックの業界に限ったこと
ではありません
女性は女性らしく
男性は男性らしく
そのような古い考え方はまだまだ世の中に
深くでついていると思います
私は今回女性マジシャンという言葉の違和
感についてシェアすることで私たちの後輩
や同じような経験を持つ人たちがその無
意識のコントロールに気づきより自由で
多様性のある選択ができるようになるため
のきっかけになればいいと思っています
最近では lgbtq など性の多様性を
尊重する動きも出てきていけ
我々マジシャンのあり方も変わりつつあり
ます
これから先
私たちがどのように歩んでいけばより
いっそ個人のありように注目してもらえる
のかについては一緒に考えていきましょう
最後に
私からマジックでメッセージを送ります
私たちはん
誰だってのもともと同じ人間のはずです
あったしかし人はついつい何かを分類し
負けたくなってしまいます
例えば
男性と女性
国籍
人種
肌の色などです
こうやって分けることで私たちは
アイデンティティを確立しているのです
しかし
分けるほどと差別することは同じではあり
ません
違いを認め尊重し多様性を受け入れること
ができたらいい
きっとこの世界バー
より
行きやすい世界になっていくと思います
[拍手]
[音楽]
ん